six one seven eight three zero 47 50
next caller is from the seven eight
seven area code what's going on I mean
Brian I'm calling some four we go hey
what's going on I heard you guys just
got full power back for the first time
since the Hurricanes is that is that
accurately reported yeah I mean last a
couple of weeks we've had 100%
restoration power there's still some
local areas that don't but it's really
getting there
cool what's uh what's on your mind today
my question involves the midterms and if
Democrats failed to materialize and win
the house do you think that Nancy Pelosi
has a responsibility to step down as
Minority Leader no no I mean listen
whatever your opinion of her as leader
that she just she doesn't automatically
have to step down if Democrats don't
retake the house I mean sure you can
attribute some responsibility to her I
think there's lots of other reasons why
Democrats could argue she's not the best
person to be leading but I don't think
that just a failure to retake the house
would mean she has to stable to step
down I mean why would you suggest it in
other words what would be an argument
for her stepping down if Democrats don't
retake the house well I think that you
know when you consider the establishment
candidates that has been sort of
prevailing in the in the primary
election and if they don't they don't
win them the you know you know enough
seat and I think that it will directly
response to me Pelosi for for keeping on
the establishment candidate instead of
promoting more progressive agenda and
more progressive candidate I don't know
Brian it's a bit of a stretch I've got
huge problems with Nancy Pelosi but a
lot of these especially House
congressional races they're they're not
really about Nancy Pelosi in any way and
the dynamics are more local so I just I
just don't know I think it's a great
let's let's talk about Nancy Pelosi not
being the
already leader great great topic I'm
totally up for that I just don't know
that that Democrats failing to retake
the house means policies gotta be out
okay thank you appreciate a call and
glad glad to hear powers back on in
Puerto Rico that's that's a story we've
been covering for a very long time and
that's good news